first question from camille
michael do you believe in ghosts in my
catholic high school i had one teacher
tell us that ghosts are in fact real but
if they are trying to interact with us
they're most likely bad because good
souls would not be in limbo in our
physical world what are your thoughts on
this sincerely who you gonna call
yes ghosts are real
they are they're real it's undeniable
that ghosts are real there is more
twixt heaven and earth than is dreamt of
in our philosophy horatio
ghosts appear in the bible sometimes you
will hear christians say ghosts if you
think you see a ghost you can say with
100 certainty it's a demon it's not
really a ghost
ghosts are in the bible
ghosts are in the first book of samuel
ghosts are in i believe second
maccabees
ghosts
are in the in the new testament
you see moses and elijah
in the transfiguration but they're not
they're they have not yet been
resurrected so they're go what is it a
ghost it comes from the word geist it
means spirit so yeah our spirit's real
yes spirits are real and
do we have evidence of them appearing
to humans
uh yeah we do actually we i know that
the material the scientific materialists
are going to laugh at me the secularists
are going to laugh at me when i say that
but yeah we have a lot of evidence one
we see it in the bible so if you're a
christian or a jew then certainly you
would have to
admit that ghosts are real but even if
you're a hardened
stone cold
agnostic or atheist
we have
reports of people seeing ghosts seeing
spirits of strange phenomena
everywhere for all of history
in every single culture in every single
place on earth up to and including the
present day
we have these unexplained phenomena we
have anecdotal tales of people seeing
spirits
things that cannot be explained so it
just seems to me as a cultural matter i
know that you probably can't see the
ghost under a microscope but it just
seems to me first of all there is more
between heaven and earth and is dreamt
of in our philosophy
if you have even the sl slightest
modicum of humility you have to admit
that
and
it seems as a cultural matter we can
infer that yes there is something going
on here we know that we have spirits
again if you're
unless you're the most hardened
materialist of all you have to admit
that we have something like a spirit
i mean transgenderism the whole
transgender ideology is based on the
idea not only that we have spirits but
that our spirits are entirely our true
selves and our body is not our true self
right so even even people who are maybe
atheistic or think that they're
atheistic or agnostic in modernity
even they
believe that there is such a thing as a
spirit
and uh yeah and and that the spirit and
the body are
distinct
and that spirits are are around
sometimes you should not uh seek out
mediums or things like that to
communicate with ghosts that's a bad
idea
you should not engage in necromancy the
bible also says don't do that that's
that's not good stuff
and they and also demons are real too i
know i mean maybe we'll wait for another
question to go into how obviously angels
and demons are real but uh yeah you i
mean sometimes demons can mess with
people so don't you know like don't seek
them out but are ghosts real 100
glad you like that clip the full episode
is called the end of the world as we
know it you can get it here on youtube
so subscribe leave a comment you know
get that going but
what i would recommend
go to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your
podcasts search for the michael knowles
show subscribe
thank you thank you for doing that leave
a five-star review we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you